Airbnb is tackling privacy concerns this
morning after several customers found
hidden cameras at the rental properties
the company told CBS News it takes
privacy extremely seriously and there is
absolutely no place in our community for
this kind of behavior and a Warner is
following the story and a good morning
good morning
Airbnb requires hosts to disclose to
guests prior to their stay if they have
any cameras on their property
the company says cameras are never
allowed in bathrooms or bedrooms but
that doesn't always stop ill-intentioned
hosts from hiding them I was like this
could be like the day that I get killed
or worse 22 year old Megan Hilton from
Washington State was in Switzerland in
2016
when she says a friend discovered a cell
phone under the sink in the bathroom at
their Airbnb we saw that the phone was
filming and we were whispering and
trying to be very quiet we weren't sure
if it was being live-streamed soon after
Hilton says they found an iPad also
recording they quickly left and reported
the incident to the company it was just
very scary and I kind of felt like this
is like one of those moments like where
if we don't get our stuff together like
something very bad could happen there
have been other similar incidents in
late November activist and filmmaker
Jason Scott tweeted his colleague found
a camera disguised in a motion detector
at an Airbnb the company called the
discovery incredibly rare and said the
host was banned and in October an
Indiana couple said they found a camera
in a smoke detector in the bedroom at
their Airbnb in Florida the homeowner
was arrested for video voyeurism
simply put property owners can be
peeping toms Cameron Russell is a
professor at Fordham Law can someone
actually legally do this can they put a
camera in a place that you're renting on
Airbnb it's conceivable if they gave you
enough specific notice so like if they
were going to do this written notice
written notice notice as to the
locations of the camera and that you
willingly consented to them in June a
German tourist settled with Airbnb for
an undisclosed amount after allegedly
finding a hidden remote-controlled
camera at a property in California
Hilton
said while air B&B refunded her for her
Switzerland stay and reimbursed her for
other travel expenses she still felt it
wasn't enough I think that was probably
the bare minimum that they could have
done to help us out for all we know he
still has the videos that were on the
iPad the company told us around 2
million people use Airbnb on any given
night and they are always willing to
work with law enforcement when
complaints are made experts say there's
a few things consumers can do to protect
themselves invest in a digital device
detector search rooms or use a
flashlight to try to spot lenses if you
want to survey your Airbnb when you get
there I guess yeah but a lot of homes
have security cameras inside them mine
does for security purpose I think the
question is disclosure do you know when
you rent it there are cameras and do you
know where they are and do you agree and
do you approve
yeah well that's a good morning sign at
the time don't approve of being recorded
in the bathroom yeah and you know I
don't think was very creepy yeah